hey guys Pete here this will be my dark
season three family trees video the
final season of this Netflix original
series answered most of the questions
related to the four families at the
center of the knot that is windin but
due to the looping nature of some of the
family relations it's a lot to take in
and keep track of in this dark season 3
video I'll be talking about the family
connection revelations we got and that
will contain spoilers that would
potentially ruin things if you haven't
finished the series for that reason I
wouldn't recommend watching this video
until you've completed the entire third
season I do have a family tree video
that I'll link to up at the top if you
want to get a refresher of who's who
while you're watching season 3 alright
then we did get some major revelations
and how things are connected with the
families and dark and it turns out that
yonis and Marta are the center of it all
of course when I say Marta I'm talking
about the one from the alternate world
the Martha from seasons 1 & 2 who Yanis
fell in love with only to find out she
was his aunt is dead and makes no
further contributions to the family
trees for that reason I'm not gonna say
alt every time I say her name
this Marta the one from the alternate
world is at the center of everything
because she conceived a child with the
onus since we've all watched the season
I won't retell the story in this video
but in relation to the families Marta
saves yonas from the apocalypse in his
world and brings him to hers he then
meets a slightly younger version of her
who doesn't know anything about time
travel yet and they end up sleeping
together she gets pregnant as a result
and that turns out to be the beginning
of all the family tree insanity she
gives birth to a character that we've
been calling the trio due to the fact
that he appears as three characters
three versions of the same character at
different points in his life a boy an
adult
and an old man this character explains
he was never given a name and is
referred to as the unknown in the
credits and official show materials the
unknown answers one of the biggest
questions we've had agnes Nielsen was
the farthest point back on the Nielsen
family line and we had no idea who
fathered her
according to the official website the
unknown conceived trauma in both worlds
with Agnes taranta then is the father of
Ulrich who is the father of Marta but
also the grandfather of yonus it's an
infinite cycle a massive knot with the
unknown at the center on screen we don't
see the unknown and agnes together and
we never visit the time when she was
pregnant with taranta the explanation
just says that he was conceived in both
worlds by the same parents another big
question we had about Agnes and her
brother Noah was who their parents were
season 3 gives us that answer and it
turns out to be cilia and bartosh
Tiedemann bartosh of course was yonis as
highschool friend that was saved by
stranger Jonas at the end of season 2 he
ended up in 1888 and was eventually
killed by younger noah who turned out to
be his son in 1921 sylia was taken care
of by elisabeth doppler in the future
until she sent back to 1890 and meets
bartosh they become a couple and have no
and Agnes together with Celia dying
while giving birth to their daughter
this is a good time to discuss the
differences in how the family tree plays
out in Adams and Ava's worlds in the
official family tree we can see that
many of the relationships still exists
but we don't get to see how they played
out in Ava's world cilia and bartosh are
still Agnes parents but we never
actually meet cilia in her world bar
tars follows a much different path
through time but as far as the family
trees are concerned we end up in the
same place silly as parentage is another
example of this we learned that her
parents are Hannah and Aegon in Adam's
world she traveled back to 1954 and met
him there they have an affair in that
time period and she gives birth to Celia
after leaving him eventually she travels
back in time where yonas / Adam kills
her and he sends cilia to the future
where she grows up until we first meet
her in 2050 - in Ava's world it isn't
clear when this happens since Hannah is
married to Ulrich in the 2019 timeline
and Aegon is a travelling member of
Ava's group Aaron
the only time we see them together is
when a gun rescues her from the
apocalypse in that world at that time
Hanna was pregnant with Ulrich's child
but she suffers a miscarriage right as
Aegon is arriving Aegon and his first
wife Doris are the parents of Claudia
Tiedemann Claudia is the mother of
Regina who gets cancer in both worlds
but we never knew for sure who her
father was
Toronto was the most likely candidate
because we knew that they had a
relationship but it turns out that burn
dopler was Regina's father all along
this felt someone out of the blue since
there were no hints to an intimate
relationship but it turns out to be
important since it means that Regina is
not a direct descendant of the Jonas and
Martha Line Regina's husband Alexander
has a mysterious backstory that fans
have long theorized about he was born
Boris nee Wald
and arrived in vinden with a gunshot
wound carrying the pistol that will
travel through time and later be used by
Adam to kill Marta from his world he
used that to run off teen Katerina and
Ulrich who were threatening Regina and
the two former relationship that sees
them get married and give birth to
bartosh his entrance into the story led
to many theories about him being a time
traveler or at least manipulated by one
but in the end it turns out he was a guy
on the run in Ava's world he tells his
son that he killed a man in marburg but
it was an accident he played a role in
the apocalypse in both worlds as
director of the power plant but he was
just a criminal who went straight after
fleeing to windin and meeting his wife
speaking of the power plant burned
dopplers wife Greta expressed doubt
about him being hailed as real father in
the conversation with Noah she says the
boy was not born out of love
leading the speculation that she may
have been raped we don't get a full
explanation of the story here but the
family tree does give us a name and
confirms that burn does not Helga's
father the name is Anatol the Lev but
there's no information about this
character held his son Peter has also
been the source of many theories because
we only had a vague backstory of him
arriving in windin in 1987 season 3
explained that Helga is his father but
he didn't know about him until
shortly before his mother died his
mother's name was all a sham it but we
don't have any other details about her
life or relationship with Helga in the
end like Boris nee wolde Peters story
turned out to be just what it looked
like on the surface of course he does
get together with Charlotte in both
worlds and pitches in on the bootstrap
paradox relationship between his wife
and daughter that they are each other's
mothers was one of the big reveals in
season 2 and I find it funny looking at
the new family tree since it's not even
really emphasized now that we know the
origin there's just one loop out of many
Charlotte's adopted grandfather HG tan
house is a character we learned a lot
about in the final season we learned
that his great-grandfather Heinrich was
the founder of sick mundis in the origin
of the gold pocket watch
Heinrich initially gave the watch as a
gift to his wife Charlotte who later
died he started sick Mundus to learn how
to time travel in order to try to bring
her back from the dead he passes the
watch on to his son Gustav who we meet
he's the blind man who owns the factory
where stranger Jonas is working on the
time machine he was killed by the
unknown as he was on his way to tell the
world about the Time Traveler's he met
stranger Jonas and Marta the unknown
takes the watch from him and it starts
his journey through time
Gustav 10 houses grandson HG is the
clock maker we met in the first two
seasons and he turns out to be the
catalyst for everything in a third
origin world I discussed all of this in
my ending explained video and will
probably revisit it in future videos but
in relation to the family trees the
website does have an easter egg if you
scroll all the way through yonus or
Martha's pages the origin worlds family
tree will appear by default you just see
mirrored versions of the family tree for
Adam and Ava's worlds we learned in the
closing scene of the series that some of
the characters from the origin world are
the same but none of the characters that
are direct descendants of Jonas and
Marta through the unknown exist this
origin world family tree shows Claudia
and Bernd are married in this world
making Regina's last name dopler we get
come from
that Hana and Torben are married making
her last name baller we can see that in
a world without Charlotte Peter winds up
with Bernadette Waller and that even
though Boris nee Wald exists it doesn't
look like he ever gets together with
Regina there's other characters that we
never saw on-screen these characters
parents that are in the family tree but
there isn't any additional information
about their lives in the origin world we
do see Katarina here her last name is
still out bears and that was one other
reveal that we got in the third season
that her parents were Hermann and Helene
al bear of course we saw her mother kill
her she was the nurse at the psychiatric
unit where Ulrich was living out his
years Hermann al bears was the man that
Egon talked to when the Sheep died back
in season one and that pretty much wraps
things up as mentioned the biggest
reveal is that all of this starts and
essentially ends with Jonas and Marta on
a bigger scale it starts with HG tan
house who like his great grandfather is
obsessed with time travel because he
wants to go back and save someone who
died we see this theme repeated
throughout the different worlds and in a
way it seems quite fitting that Jonas
and Marta who would never have existed
in the origin world are able to complete
this process making for at least a
reality where ten houses family never
dies and he never decides to invent a
time machine what an absolute mess and
not it does feel great to have all the
answers now there's a couple things
there become people we don't know they
never told us who Hannah's mother was or
or Daniel Conwell's wife but in the end
they didn't turn out to be important but
beyond that we did get answers to all
the big questions and with that I think
I'll leave it there let me know in the
comments what you think did you catch
all this were you able to keep track of
it while you were watching season 3 do
you have any other questions about the
family trees that I didn't cover I'll be
making more dark videos this week so let
me know if you have any ideas in the
comments as well as mentioned I did put
out an ending explain video you should
check that out if you haven't please
like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already I'll put
a link in the description to the
official website where all these family
trees come from a lot of your questions
can be answered there they filled in a
lot of blanks I've been going through
that for days at this point and that's
about it thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon